[Music]
a coach from the
court county school district is free on
bail how are you greetings cristian
cásseres I tell you that will the price
prox 42 years old there he has it on screen he
is free after being arrested
for attempted conduct in the
sexual property firefox was the coach of
the
us airways high school girls basketball team is the police
16 and says the investigation began
earlier this month after receiving a
report from a 17-year-old student he
is scheduled to appear in court on 16
february the nfl asks a
nevada judge to dismiss the lawsuit filed
by former
las vegas raiders' coach franklin the lawsuit
originated from the disclosure of
emails sent by
kring 10 years ago which led to
resign from the team this request says that
the emails are based on their own
facts
the hardware now owns the brunch
and through the changes the icon does not
appear  nico volcano of the resort the new
owner has plans to change the
facade of the hotel and includes a giant guitar next
to the property the
continued of the hardware works xiaobin i know
they are going to delay the volcano and now we
take a look at the temperatures
we will have one day  sunny with highs
reaching 62 degrees there will be some
breezes as well which will carry over into
tomorrow but won't impact the weather
we will stay in the 60s for the rest of the
week this is cristian caceres with your brief
ignition briefing spanish good day